[Music]
freddy is in iowa or i'm sorry louisiana
hey freddy how are you
very well sir thank you how are you
better than i deserve what's up
um sir i'm fixing to retire i'm seven
years old my wife is 62
uh we
have a home we have a very small
mortgage on it
we have have uh
five steps it's appeared in bean
construction
and she's laid up right now with a broke
foot and she'll be laid up until january
and every time i go up and down them
steps like i was telling the gentleman
want to go it's a land mine and it's
gonna bite me one day
uh we're we're wanting to build a new
home uh
on slab uh
have it
not necessarily handicapped accessible
but more friendly toward toward our age
okay uh i'm wondering
the main thing i'm wondering about right
now is should we go ahead and do this in
the next few months begin
or should we wait a year or so
well i don't want to get laid up in
cripples where i can't yeah i'm anything
i don't want you to either um
and if i thought that was the only
option i you know we would talk about it
but obviously it's not
um i mean you made it up down those
steps a bunch of times you probably got
a few more in you but the uh but yeah
let's go ahead and have a plan
um i'm actually drawing a home right now
i'm thinking i'm probably going to build
in the spring
and
maybe
if everything has calmed down a little
bit
but uh but the you know as you know the
real estate world has been out of
control
oh yeah crazy
and so you don't want it you don't want
to be building a house in the middle of
crazy and some builders act like they're
doing you a favor but oh yes we will
consider building your home
uh no you got this backward bud
so i'm the one giving you money so uh
you know this you know kind of getting
on the right side of that equation and i
don't know in your area if you're there
you could certainly interview a few
builders and look at some plans and say
okay this is what we want to do and see
if you get a the right attitude and b if
they can give you reasonable pricing
based on uh construction materials
availability supply and demand cost
right now
most of that has evened out after the
the uh pandemic economic suppression
when we shut down the world to flatten
the curve you all remember that that was
weird and um
now we're trying to catch up on all the
production that was not done in the
factories and it caused inflation
and so now that there's not as much
scarcity and there's a little bit more
abundance of the items some of the
prices are starting to stabilize the
components of a home for instance lumber
prices that kind of stuff so that's what
we're facing right now
check it out right now
but um
personally i'm thinking it's going to be
spring for it's going to get a little
bit more normal this is the ramsey show